Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today.
Bill Share, who is contributor to the Washington
Monthly and Real Clear Politics, also host
of the history podcast When America Worked.
Bill, always great having you on.
Speaker 3: Always great to talk to you.
Speaker 1: So I'm trying to understand different
individuals motivations in either being in
favor of or against the various iterations
of the infrastructure proposals that we've
been seeing now for for several months.
Let's kind of start with what's been more
in the news, which is maybe Joe Manchin, Joe
Manchin and Kirsten Cinema.
When I step back and think about West Virginia,
you know, 47th in health care, very close
to 50th, if not 50th in education, very poor
infrastructure would be a place that would
really benefit from exactly this.
It would seem like, hey, his constituents
would reward him for getting them some money.
And then the story that's now floating around
is, well, look at his income from fossil fuel
companies that would be hurt by the climate
piece of this.
Is it?
Is it as simple as a follow the money type
thing?
Speaker 3: Well, I don't want to play mind
reader, and I understand people wanting to
connect dots, and everyone's welcome to have
their own theories.
Sure.
But you people went into this year thinking,
Oh, Manchin likes the posture, but this is
essentially a populous state, and so he'll
do the populist thing.
Yeah, and now he's not doing the populist
thing.
So they're coming up with fresh theories.
I think you look at Manchin's longer record
in politics from his very early days in West
Virginia.
He has always been a business friendly centrist
that has always been his thing.
It's not new.
And why he's a business really centrist.
You're welcome to have your own theories about
that, but that just seems to be the case.
And.
Are you at the end of the day, if you want
this bill to pass, you need his vote.
However annoying it is to get that vote, it
is needed.
And I think this is also true for cinema.
I think the strategy of brow beating them
publicly.
And challenging their political acumen, accusing
them of corruption.
It may all be true, but it's not getting you
their vote.
They're not being shamed into moving off their
position.
So I think a different tack needs to be taken.
If they're if you're going to get to 50, which
may be happening, that we're seeing the conversation
is starting to materialize now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you and I both, I think,
tweeted a disfavor about following Kirsten
Cinema into the bathroom.
And as I said, you know what I said on my
show was maybe you could make the case that
the bathroom is the only place where she might
be confronted by an opposing view.
It seems contrary to reality, and thus that
is a tactic doesn't seem to me to be particularly
productive.
But what?
What can be done to effectively pressure a
lot of these folks who, you know, the voters
swam up to the yacht of Joe Manchin, and it
wasn't particularly inspiring the things that
he said to me like what actually works to
pressure these people from from an individual
voter standpoint,
Speaker 3: you know, different tactics work,
different people.
There's not a one size fits all here, but
at minimum, for the last several weeks of
months, people have tried confrontation.
People have tried give you their personal
spaces.
People have tried haranguing them as being
on the take.
And not only have they not moved, they seem
to have, you know, dug in their heels.
And even at the precise moment when progressives
thought they were gaining more leverage by
blocking the the bipartisan infrastructure
bill that Joe Manchin spearheaded, Sinema
essentially wrote It's called cinema Portman,
for Pete's sake.
Yeah, thinking, Well, we hold that hostage,
that what's prize to them?
They'll have to come up to come around almost
immediately.
That price tag on build back better went down
by nearly 50 percent.
Right.
So the tactics just aren't working.
And so I just think the entire approach of
treating them as effectively adversaries,
people who are not progressive, who don't
see the world the way we do and need to be
dragged in doing the right thing.
That approach isn't working.
I think you want to get the temperature down.
You want to get into the same room with them
and try to talk to them and figure out where
is the common ground?
I mean, there's no common.
There's no common ground.
I think there is some common ground.
You got to find where that is and not make
it into a grudge match because a grudge match
isn't working in progressives favor.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I do think that part of what
makes it difficult is it seems as though Joe
Manchin is very dishonest.
And what I mean by that is for a while, he
was saying the problem was the price tag.
As you mentioned, iterations of this have
seen a much reduced price tag.
And now he doesn't like it for different reasons.
So part of it is maybe, maybe common ground
is the way to describe that.
But also moving goalposts seems to be a real
problem here.
Speaker 3: Well, both Manchin and cinema can
be.
I mean, Manchin can use a lot of word salad,
which makes him inscrutable in certain ways.
And cinema is very quiet, which makes her
inscrutable.
And this frustrates the hell out of progressives.
I think it's a negotiating tactic is working
very well for them, and everyone's chasing
their votes, right?
Throwing things at them to figure what's going
to make them happy.
So they're in the driver's seat.
I don't think it's fair to say Manchin has
moved the goalpost because he has been consistent
on a number of things.
You look at that piece of paper that he signed
with Chuck Schumer back in July.
Now, granted, this wasn't known to the rest
of us at the time, but he communicated this
to his majority leader of all the things that
he wanted that he was comfortable with.
And essentially by omission what he was not
comfortable with.
That's all been pretty consistent.
He's been saying for a long time.
He doesn't like this clean energy payment
program, which was written to be the centerpiece
of the climate section of the bill.
That's not new.
So I think he's always had a combination of
price tag concerns and substantive concerns,
and people have tried to grind him down instead
of accepting that he holds a determining vote.
And so what are his concerns?
De facto become your concerns.
You need to resolve those concerns to get
a bill.
Speaker 1: There is many progressives who
every time this happens, say we got a primary
Joe Manchin, and whenever that happens, I
tend to think, Well, I don't know that if
a further left Democrat wins the primary,
they actually win the general Senate election
in West Virginia that might lead to replacing
a Democrat with a Republican.
I think we need to be solving this.
You solve 50 50 by taking some existing Republican
seats and turning them to Democratic seats.
What's your general perspective on this idea
of Prime?
Marrying Joe Manchin, even as a pressure tactic
to get him to be scared in some way.
Speaker 3: Well, he's been primaried and he's
unfazed.
So I mean, West Virginia is just too red.
The fact that Joe Manchin is there at all
is a gift for Democrats.
They should be.
They will not have a majority without Joe
Manchin right now.
It would be Mitch McConnell, and we would
be talking about a multitrillion dollar bill
at all.
So Manchin shrugs that off very gleefully.
Now, cinema is a different story.
Yes.
Cinema seems to have a theory of the case
that she doesn't care, either if she gets
primaried, that her path of success is, you
know, is mavericky.
A. McCain like independence from party leadership,
and even though those primary threats are
more pronounced and are very vocalized right
now, again, she is not budging.
So I understand worth trying it out to see
if it might get her running scared, but she's
not running scared.
So, I mean, it may be by 2024, which is up.
She'll lose that primary.
I can't say I think she will probably survive
a primary.
It's very unusual for an incumbent to be ousted
in a primary, particularly ideological reasons.
Usually, if it happens, it's for a scandal
reason.
So Arizona is still pretty purple.
It's not hard blue, and there are a lot of
people in Arizona even who are Democrats who
say electability comes first.
So I would still put my money on cinema surviving,
but it's certainly not a slam dunk.
But nevertheless, she is not being cowed by
that pressure tactic.
Speaker 1: What is going to or less will work
backwards?
Does this bill's passage or failure affect
Democrats in 2022?
Is it the type of thing that voters would
actually vote one way or the other on?
Does Joe Biden getting something else big
done impact Democrats in 2022?
What does matter looking at the midterms?
Speaker 3: Well, there's two ways to look
at 2022.
One is Democrats are going to lose no matter
what.
The midterm princess party, they always lose
something.
The margins are so narrow that just the tiniest
tiniest bit of something means it's all over.
So get what you can.
While you can even worry about the politics,
right?
One school of thought not illegitimate.
The other is, you know, even though it doesn't
usually happen, it can happen.
It's happened three times in the past.
You know, I think post-reconstruction that
the president's party has gained a few seats
and I think a fourth time when they just lost
a very, very little enough that Democrats
could actually survive this time around.
And when those things happen, it's almost
always because there's some kind of crisis.
And the president's party is seen as managing
that crisis as well.
And so the usual dynamic of the president's
party's coalition splintering because of the
natural realities of governing trade offs
compromises imperfections are unfulfilled
aspirations and dreams, things that deplete
some of your base or make some people the
middle peel off while your opposition is unified
against whatever it is the president's party
is doing.
That's the reason why the president's party
usually loses.
So if Democrats can't pass, build back better
at all, or if it's reduced to such a nub that
it makes people some people unhappy, that
makes some people on the base displeased.
You know, even if it's a good general election
politics, it's good for the center if that
base is unhappy.
You know, if any, if any faction is unhappy,
that's bad for the midterms.
You need full unity to overcome the historical
trend.
So that's another reason why it's not good
for Democrats to be in this tug of war right
now, where someone's going to feel bad regardless
of the outcome.
You want everyone to feel good about the outcome,
even though it's almost certainly going to
be some kind of compromise.
Speaker 1: What about something like the Afghanistan
withdrawal, which, by the way, I was and remain
completely in favor of and believe it would
have been just as if not more chaotic under
Donald Trump, but that ultimately it's the
right decision when that took place in August
into September.
There was a lot of talk of this will torpedo
the midterms for Democrats, and I really didn't
see it for two reasons.
One, that it really was a Biden thing.
And of course, it can affect the midterms.
We're talking about that.
But number two, it just seems like it.
There is enough time between then and the
midterms and the relatively short memories
of voters struck me as I don't think Afghanistan
is going to play a factor in the midterms.
What do you think?
Speaker 3: I mean, I wrote a piece to that
effect at the Washington Monthly at the time
when I said with the caveat of some kind of
9-11 occurring, some kind of terrorist attack
on our soil launched from Afghanistan because
it turns out that was able to regroup under
the current circumstances.
That would be, you know, obviously.
Bad for people's lives and bad for Democrats
politically.
Outside of that, I think we're already seeing
Afghanistan fading into the background of
politics.
Having said that?
Biden has not had a single day with a good
headline since early August when the Afghanistan
withdrawal occurred.
And if it's Afghanistan, it's COVID Delta
variant, it's not COVID, it's something on
the border, but it's saying the border is
the infrastructure bill being blocked, the
infrastructure bill being blocked.
It's that build back better is in limbo or
there's a debt limit drama.
You know, it's always something.
Yeah, and there hasn't been a good day.
And Afghanistan was just the first time when
there was an obviously bad day or people sort
of saying, Wait a second, maybe these guys
don't know what they're doing.
Maybe they're not perfect.
Maybe they're not the most competent operation
in the universe.
You can fix that with some wins, but putting
some points on the board, which is why I wonder.
I mean, I can't I can't predict this, and
it's not the way it panned out.
You know, two and half weeks ago, but we are
coming up on another deadline on October 30,
first where Nancy Pelosi said we need to pass
the bipartisan infrastructure bill by this
date because the Highway Trust Fund is going
to expire now.
She said the same thing a month ago, and what
happened a month ago was that Progressive
said, We don't care.
We're not going to give you the votes.
Biden came to the House and said, Look, this
has to be done at the same time.
And then people scrambled and pass the Highway
Trust Fund extension for 30 days, and Progressive
essentially said this isn't a real deadline
because you can push that off.
They were proven correct.
However, you can only push off that highway
trust fund deadline if Republicans in the
Senate agree.
That's not.
It's not a reconciliation vote.
That's a regular order vote.
Republicans did that last month because they
said this isn't.
This isn't costing the extra money.
There's enough money in the kitty for the
provincial government to pay out what's needed
for road and transit projects for states and
localities.
But that may not be the case two weeks from
now.
So it's a real hard deadline, I should say.
One of their negative headline the past two
weeks has been the supply chain issue.
Yes, Biden is saying he's trying to fix that.
He knows it's a serious problem.
And over the long haul, we need to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure bill because it
invests money in ports and freight rail.
So he's connecting those two things right
now.
Do they really want to have the Highway Trust
Fund, you know, lapse?
So no moneys paid out to states, localities
for infrastructure projects indefinitely while
there is a supply chain crisis going on right?
Might Biden come back to the House in two
weeks and say, Look, we're in a jam here,
people, you know, we're not going anywhere,
build back better.
We got a supply chain problem.
My polls are in the dumps, so we're trying
to be the infrastructure party.
We can't be having infrastructure projects
get throttled over.
I mean, it wouldn't happen and instead want
to be like all of a sudden everyone drops
their their jackhammers.
But states no cars would not know over time
if the money was coming, and that would cause
a lot of disruptions and people would vocally
complain, Do you want those kind of complaints
happening at the state and local level?
Well, we've had months and months of inactivity
from Democrats might bite Biden, come in and
put his thumb on the scale the other way and
say, I need you on this vote now.
I need you to suck it up and pass this vote
right now.
Predicting it, I'm using those factors are
in the mix.
And one other factor in the mix, I should
add Virginia.
November 2nd is the Virginia gubernatorial
election, Terry McAuliffe, the Democratic
nominee, is saying, I'm sick of these Democrats
in Washington not getting stuff done.
We need this infrastructure bill passed and
some people fear if McAuliffe loses, then
everything is going to fall apart.
That Manchin cinema will be even harder to
get and harder to kowtow to progressives.
Good.
They'll say that it's your intransigence that
led to this calamity in Virginia.
I might say it's your intransigence because
you wouldn't do things our way and just be
hard and hard to come to come to terms.
So what all that come together and make Democrats
suck it up on the infrastructure bill?
Not predicting, but those are different factors
that were not present a month ago.
Speaker 1: So where are you predicting or
not?
I'm not.
I'm not sure.
No, I'm kidding.
No.
Speaker 3: I couldn't go that far, but I might
still conclude, Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He doesn't want to be a source of party disunity,
right?
No, I'm kidding.
Hesitant to push one faction over the other.
Yeah.
But I do think of a different set of factors
than you did a month ago.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt, without a doubt.
Bill Share contributor to the Washington Monthly
and Real Clear Politics, host of the history
podcast One America Worked.
Bill, always a pleasure.
Speaker 3: Same here.
Take care.